فيديو جديد من وزارة
الدفاع الروسية حيث تزعم أن بعض الوحدات
قد أكملت تدريباتها
وتعود الآن إلى قواعدها الرئيسية ،
ولم يحدد الجيش الروسي
المواقع في مقاطع الفيديو CNN ولكن تم تحديد موقع
جغرافي لساحة سكة حديد واحدة حيث
كانت هذه الدبابات.  تم تحميله على متن
قطار في شبه جزيرة القرم ، وسئل عما إذا كان الناتو
قادرًا على التحقق من التأكيدات الروسية بأن
بعض الوحدات ستعود إلى الوطن ،
أخبرني رئيس وزراء إستونيا أننا لم
نصدق ذلك عندما نراه ولكننا لا
نراه الآن
روسيا
فعلت ذلك  التعزيزات العسكرية حول
أوكرانيا لأشهر بالفعل ، لذلك لم
يحدث شيء في أيام قليلة أو ساعات قليلة
ولم نشهد أي خفض حقيقي للتصعيد
حتى الآن
ولا يزال هناك الكثير من
الدروع الروسية بالقرب من أوكرانيا وتقترب أكثر من
بين وسائل النقل الوافدة الحديثة
و  طائرات الهليكوبتر الهجومية
هذه في قاعدة مرتجلة بالقرب من
بيلغورود على بعد أميال قليلة من
الحدود الأوكرانية ولعل أبرز
هذه الصور التي تظهر أكثر من 60
طائرة هليكوبتر في  مطار مهجور في
شمال غرب شبه جزيرة القرم ، لم يكن هناك شيء
قبل أيام قليلة فقط ، المروحيات
المعروضة عبارة عن مزيج من طائرات الهجوم والنقل على بعد
حوالي 40 ميلاً من
الساحل الجنوبي لأوكرانيا
قبالة الساحل مباشرة ،
أبلغت وسائل الإعلام التابعة لوزارة الدفاع الروسية عن
التدريبات البحرية للبحر الأسود  التي تضم
حوالي 30 سفينة في صور الأقمار الصناعية ، اكتشف ماكسار
أيضًا أن القوات الجوية الروسية
نشرت ما لا يقل عن 10 قاذفات هجومية من طراز Su-34
في مطار بالقرب من كراسنودار في
جنوب
روسيا ، يقع المطار على بعد حوالي 70 ميلاً عبر
بحر آزوف من الساحل الأوكراني.
سيكون قبل أيام قليلة من
أن تؤكد صور ومقاطع الفيديو الإخبارية للأقمار الصناعية
أن جزءًا على الأقل من القوة البالغ قوامها 130
ألف جندي روسي قد
ابتعد بالفعل عن أوكرانيا
في الوقت الحالي ، وبقيت قوة كبيرة على الأرض
في الجو وفي البحر على ثلاثة
جوانب من أوكرانيا  جيم شودو CNN كيث